[Music]  hello  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  welcome to iTunes no body ladies and  gentlemen are you ready to see the next  big thing let's hear it for the new gens  it's cool  what's that Annie all children must be  accompanied by an adult you're coming  with me lady  [Music]  hello maybe we could try and be friends  you're gonna stay here tonight not you  mom oh I knew that you judging me bro  yeah you being here is like the best  thing to happen to me why don't you put  weapons in a robot something terrible is  about to happen  holy mother toast seven seven two three  is our only hope there's way too much  injustice in the world together we can  fix it I promise I got your back  [Music]  No  he's so cool what do you call him my  friend Wow  thank you for opening me oh look out  here I go closing  [Music]  you